all right joining us now investigative
reporter and Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter along with the national border
patrol council president Brandon Judd is
there good to see you both you know Joe
Biden said oh there's going to be chaos
this week There's been nothing but chaos
uh Sarah uh we have over 6 million
people about six and a half billion when
you count in godaways that have already
come into this country illegally uh with
the help of Joe Biden he's aiding and
abetting the law breaking uh without any
consequences at all and now it's about
to get worse
right Sean it is going to get worse and
it's already worse and what they've done
is they're trying to hide this from the
American people they're trying to keep
this from the American people even today
when I was interviewing Senator Bud they
had requested that I turned the camera
and ask him the questions so that the
audience could not see the people that
were lining up to get on the buses even
the buses themselves of course darkened
windows I could tell you this we have
football fields football fields of
people lining up coming into this
country and tens of thousands more over
the other side of the border and Brandon
and I have both been witnessing how many
children also how many uh male aged
males military aged males uh just coming
across the border filling busloads this
is what is happening right now at the
behest of the Biden Administration John
uh Sean and we are now witnessing
probably one of the worst in our modern
history uh situations here at the U.S
Southern border Brandon let's get your
take on it we now see these massive
crowds coming in is there any
documentation for example are we doing
any background checks I mean we have six
and a half million people enter this
country in the middle of a pandemic uh
nobody had a health check there was no
vaccine mandate there's no background
check to see if they had radical
associations no check to see if they
would be a financial burden on the
American people at a time when we cannot
afford uh to pay for schooling and
Health Care Etc we have 31 trillion
dollars in debt is there any of that
going on at all
absolutely not the only thing that we do
is we fingerprint them to see if they
have a criminal record here in the
United States we also look to see if
they have an Interpol hit and that's it
we can't check anything that's happening
in their countries if they have a
criminal record in their country we're
never going to know about it and when
you look at what what the the
Administration has done they've
completely and totally turned up turned
upside down what we have always done as
far as the enforcement aspect of it we
could get this under control tomorrow
all we have to do is go back to the
policies that President Trump
implemented Joe Biden stole those
policies from us he stole every single
one of our our enforcement tools that
would allow us to get this under control
we can keep the American public safe but
the only way we can do it is if we we
re-implement the rule of law without
that the American public is going to
Suffer Well Brandon let me ask you this
because Joe Biden early in his
presidency told people uh illegal
immigrants that if you're fleeing
oppression you should come to our border
now he's saying in the lead up to this
that the Border will be chaotic this
week yet we have Alejandro mayorkas DHS
secretary and Biden repeatedly lying to
us by saying oh no no the border is
secure I don't believe Your Lying Eyes
we're seeing you know literally millions
of people enter this country he's aiding
and abetting these people in this effort
if I went down to the border and I
picked up people in a truck and I drove
them to another state would I be guilty
of human trafficking
you would and you should be arrested and
you should be and you should go to
prison so should Joe Biden if he wasn't
the president of the United States I
would arrest him but he is the president
so he's he's not held accountable and
the the other main problem is is the
media the media doesn't hold him
accountable all of this chaos can go
away tomorrow I hate political rhetoric
I hate listening to secretary Marcus
because he never offers any evidence he
doesn't give any facts he completely
lies he's telling he tells us over and
over again the border secure it's not
secure it's not been secure they've done
everything to Make It Wide Open that's
what's happened
and Sean the reason why I know that he
lies is because before he was even
confirmed I spoke with him I told him
exactly what he needed to do I spoke
with the Biden transition team before he
took office I told them what they needed
to do they completely ignored everything
and they allowed this chaos to happen
because they wanted it to happen it is
by Design Sarah we're talking about
human trafficking we're talking about
young girls being sexually abused you
have covered that story you've shown us
evidence never mind Fentanyl and meth
and cocaine and opioids and heroin also
Crossing that border killing our
children
Sean our children are dying our citizens
are dying obviously from counterfeit
pills and Fentanyl but migrant children
are dying are being abused or being put
into work camps are being used a
bisexual predators and sold Even in our
own country and it's the Biden
Administration and President Biden that
is perpetuating this and they are making
the cartel stronger and the Human
Trafficking Organization stronger
because they are aiding and abetting
those organizations that is what is
happening in our country and somebody
has to tell the truth and somebody has
to put a stop to it all right Brandon
Sarah thank you both we appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else